mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
i'm thinking of two regular polygons
one polygon has m sides and dm diagonals
and the other has n sides and dn
diagonals
if dm plus dn is equal to 125
solve for the value of m plus n
a version of this problem was asked in
the 2018 mathcounts national competition
students had less than one minute to
solve this problem without the use of a
calculator
i admit it took me about five minutes to
solve so i think it's okay if you take
longer to solve this problem
i think patrick from germany for the
suggestion
pause if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
i'm first going to present two formulas
for the number of diagonals in a polygon
with k sides where k is greater than or
equal to 3.
i'll then illustrate how to solve the
problem quickly
one formula is an explicit formula
dk is equal to k multiplied by k minus 3
all over 2.
this is useful if you want to evaluate a
particular value like k is equal to 100
another formula is known as the
recursive formula
this is dk is equal to dk minus 1 plus k
minus 2.
this is useful for computing the next
value if you know the previous value
this is useful if you want to create a
table which is what we need to do in
this problem
before i get to that let me prove both
of these formulas
i'll first prove the explicit formula by
direct counting in a polygon with k
sides we have k vertices
how many diagonals can we draw from a
particular vertex
well notice that the adjacent vertices
will form sides with this vertex so
these two sides will not be diagonals of
this polygon
we also cannot draw a diagonal between
the vertex and itself so these three
vertices will be excluded in the count
of drawing diagonals from this vertex
but every other vertex will form a
diagonal with this vertex
therefore we have k minus 3 diagonals
that we can draw from this vertex
if we do this for all k vertices we have
k multiplied by k minus three
now we have to make one more adjustment
every single diagonal involves two
different vertices
to avoid double counting we therefore
have to divide this by two
and thus we have k multiplied by k minus
3 all over 2 and that's one way to prove
the explicit formula
another way to prove it is by
considering the complete graph
consider k vertices as before
now let's connect every pair of vertices
with an edge
in total we will have k choose two edges
because every pair of vertices will make
an edge
now every edge is either a side or a
diagonal of this polygon
but remember there are k sides to this
polygon
if we subtract the second equation from
the first we get a count of the number
of diagonals
k choose 2 is equal to k multiplied by k
minus 1 over 2 and when we subtract k we
get k multiplied by k minus 3 all over 2
and thus we've proven the formula in
another way
so now let me prove the recursive
formula
suppose we have k minus 1 vertices and
we have a formula that counts the number
of diagonals
how many more diagonals will we have if
we add one more vertex that is if we
have a k sided polygon with k vertices
well as before these three cases will
not be diagonals of this new polygon
but every other connection will be a
diagonal of the polygon so we need to
add on k minus 3 more diagonals
now if we connect the adjacent vertices
to make sides of this polygon
let's examine what happens to this
previous side of the previous polygon
with k minus 1 vertices
we'll notice that this will actually be
a diagonal of the new polygon so we need
to add one more to this formula
the result is that dk is equal to dk
minus one plus k minus three plus one
and that simplifies to be dk minus one
plus k minus 2 and that's the recursive
formula we'll need to solve this problem
quickly so now let's solve the problem
quickly
for fun let's see how long it takes
we'll first create a table for the
number of diagonals a triangle with
three sides has zero diagonals a
quadrilateral has two diagonals to get
d5 we take d4 plus three this will be
equal to five then d6 is equal to d5
plus four so we get nine
to get seven we add 5 to get 8 we add 6
and we quickly compute all of the values
in this table
we want to exceed 125 diagonals
then we look for a pair that has a sum
of 125 this will be 35 plus 90
corresponding to d10 plus d15 therefore
m plus n is equal to 10 plus 15 which is
equal to 25 and that's our answer and we
solved it in just under 40 seconds
i think this is a really fun problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you